dr. Arthur Schlesinger jr.
author of the dish uniting of America
reflections on a multicultural society
this is the third time this book's come
out how come it is the third time it was
originally published Whittle publishers
now extinct that is in the kind of
special edition which was distributed
free and then the wjop norton took it up
republished it in the trade edition and
the time is fast and the time has come
to make some new points and update the
rest and hence the third version what's
new in this one what's new in this one
well partly an updating of matters
partly some new issues have emerged but
I can tell you about and partly because
the publisher thought it'd be a good
idea to have what he calls the sizing or
syllabus at the end the baker's dozen
books which all Americas ought to read
to understand the country in which they
live
let's talk about that a baker's dozen
that dozen books that you've selected
what which one of the all those is the
most important let's hard to say which
is most important like asking witness
which is the most important of your
children I suppose but I pressed one
might argue that the most perceptive
book written about America is still
Tocqueville's democracy in America it's
an extraordinary thing that in court
c-span is how it doesn't find work
reminding people of the tough fields
significant significance the fact that
the book written 150 years ago should
still illuminate the American character
in the American experience is very
remarkable you have Ralph Waldo Emerson
Harriet Beecher Stowe Mark Twain James
Bryce William James Henry Adams Henry
Adams pops up then a lot of the readings
that I've done for this show as a the
education of Henry Adams being one of
the most important books ever written
why is it well it's a brilliant
come he's a brilliant historian because
he had some extraordinary insights one
of the his insights was the increase in
the velocity of history the rate of
change she talked about talks in the
education about the law of acceleration
and we can see this I mean the movement
every day surrounds us all the time I
think Henry Adams was born just as we
are reaching the end of one great
structural change in our society the
shift from a farm base to a factory
based economy he saw that but he
anticipated not in precise terms but in
the general sense this shift we are now
experiencing this is a shift from a
factory based economy to a computer
based economy he did not know about the
computer but he knew that something the
law of acceleration was hurtling us into
a future which where things would be
very different one of your baker's dozen
his gunnar myrdal's an American dilemma
1944 and you write a lot about that in
the book itself how did you marry the
two putting it on your list and also
referring to it in the book itself
well Mira doll's book mara dara was a
Swedish economist who's brought us to
tell you the race problem the idea of
the foundation brought him their idea
was that he could bring a certain
detachment and there were a certain
perspective which might be useful for
Americans and as this extraordinary book
in the both only the depiction of
conditions half a century ago and if you
read an American dilemma
you cannot it's hard to deny that great
changes great improvements have taken
place we haven't gone far enough but
there's extraordinary changes in
American life but he also proposed an
argument as to how these changes might
be to come about and he identified what
he called the American creed and he felt
that the American creed put certain
ideals in the minds of Americans ideals
were imperfectly fulfill
often betrayed by white America but that
in the longer run the struggle for
America soul we result in the in an
increasing fulfillment of those ideals
that those I and also the American creed
provided means by which those who are
excluded from the full benefits of
American citizenship provided means by
which they could carry out a legal and
constitutional fight for their rights
it's a remarkable book you saying in
this book that the US has worked so far
what do you mean by that
we have held together more or less
accepted parts for the Civil War and
what I meant by that was that we are in
a stage with the end of the Cold War of
a where ancient tribal antagonisms
ethnic anti rivalries and so on our
birthday which had been repressed by the
Cold War are beginning to burst out one
nation after another is being torn apart
by this I mean in the murderous farm in
Yugoslavia or we've seen they what
horrors religious and national rivalries
can generate even in a nation as
tranquil and peaceful as Canada Canada's
on the verge of bust up because it was a
different linguistic and ethnic district
additions I think that all this suggests
that that you can push suggest that we
ought to pay more attention to what
holds the nation together we're in there
living at a time of the breaking of
nations for ethnic tribal religious
reasons I think one reason why I wanted
to revise the book the dis uniting of
America but I think we're more sensitive
now to they need to find things that
hold us together than we were when the
book first came out I think the
Yugoslavia experiences reminded
Americans that if you press ethnic
rivalries too far if you did
decide the people belong irrevocably to
one or another ethnic community ethnic
tribe that may be the roads of trouble
and that there is some virtue in the
older idea of assimilation and
integration that is we are after all
Americans the melting pot has worked on
evenly it's worked imperfectly but it
has produced the ideal of one people the
first time I spoke came I was nineteen
ninety one then it was redone in 1992
and now in 1998 and you say in the book
that history is a weapon what do you
mean by that history is a weapon history
ideally strives for objectivity above
the battle and so on but historians like
everyone else have prisoners they were
their own experience their own times and
very active so the selection of facts
from the past involves an interpretation
a sense of priorities a sense of values
as to what what matters history can be a
very strong weapon for people who wish
to to construct a certain movement in a
certain direction history and for
example has been the victim of
nationalism often what's happening in
Yugoslavia what's happening in Ireland
George Mitchell or who did this superb
job in bringing about the peace
settlement in Ireland he used to say
that he once said to me you kiss
torian's are worried about fact that
young Americans don't even know much of
their history I said yes it we are
baffled every sin well but people don't
know when the Civil War took place and
so on
he said the trouble of Ireland is that
they know too much of their own history
and they try to reenact it and of course
later there
filled with resentment so variances that
took place after century ago century ago
300 years ago back to Droid and Cromwell
so that history can be a weapon in the
sense of vindication of people's desire
to get back at somebody else or to move
in one direction or another I think that
one show that sees this in the
construction that these days of
curriculum where is the feeling is that
people ought to be made we ought to
become proud of their ancestors and so
we get into a kind of ethnic
cheerleading which i think is at the
expensive of realistic history you know
when we sat down here I asked you how to
pronounce your name correctly why don't
you do it one more time
well I say sleazing it that's the german
pronunciation but it's a matter of
fielder's choice I can't even get my
wife to pronounce it correctly but you
point out in in you talk about your
father a couple times in this book and
you mentioned Xenia Ohio where were you
born I was born in Columbus Ohio my
father was born in Xenia and my father
was a moment as historian than his son
he was a great leader in the cause of
social history half a century ago the
history of immigration history of women
he was but he was one of the pioneers in
the enlargement of history in what would
be now called the Malay cultural
direction what year did he die he died
in 1965 and what did his father do his
father was they came to this country
just before the Civil War as a as a
young boy brother over here and moved to
moved out to Xenia Ohio where'd he come
from
he came from Germany whereabouts in
German pressure he was a great admirer
of the ardent Democrat and the great
admirer of Grover Cleveland and when my
father was born in 1888 Cleveland was
coming
for reelection he wanted the name this
new baby Grover Cleveland's phasing it
fortunately my grandmother and my
father's two older sisters intervened
and saved my father from that fate if
not I might be well be Grover seats
facing a junior today
well why Xenia Ohio what was the what
was the draw there geniu was this was
this small Pleasant small town it was a
kind of local it's a county seat of
Greene County in Ohio and seemed a
thriving place used to have and Harper
house theater and so on
and my grandfather liked it very much he
was very strong supporter of education
particularly the public library at the
Carnegie Library in Xenia what do you do
for a living he was an insurance agent
and then how did your father become a
historian he went to my father went to
Ohio State and when did it be a
newspaperman because he had been you
know when he was high school local the
Zinio correspondent for a Cincinnati
paper but he did so well in at Ohio
State that his professors who said that
he should go undergraduate work at
Columbia they got a fellowship the
Columbia came on to New York and fell
under the influence of James Harvey
Robinson then Charles a beard and I
don't want to become a historian and
then how long did you spend in Columbus
on
I left Columbus Ohio about the age of
one and my memories are not vivid my
father left a lot of state to go go to
the University of Iowa where he became
head of the history department and then
a few years later when I was about six
years old Samuel Eliot Morrison at
Harvard it became Harmsworth professor
at Oxford for a year and he'd met my
father and he recommended that my father
be brought to Cambridge to
that's a visiting professor to take his
place for that year and my father came
to Cambridge then after year they
offered him a permanent job too so I
from the age of six or seven I grew up
in Cambridge Massachusetts and where did
you go to school I went to public
schools I went to Phillips Exeter
Academy I went to Harvard I spent a year
at Cambridge University and you've got a
PhD and I don't have you know I know
they I after I spent the earth I
graduated in college in 1938 I spent the
year 38:39 in Cambridge strange twilight
year between Munich and the war I then
came back joining something called the
Society of fellows at Harvard which is
established by former president
hey Lawrence Lowe who didn't was not
enthusiastic about the PhD system so
this was for people who could do what
they wanted to do for a term of three
years so long as I didn't work for a PhD
well by the time the my three years was
up the we were at war and I would got
involved in that by the time I got back
from overseas in 1945 I'd already
written a couple of books and seemed no
point in getting a PhD you've written
how many books I forget there's listed
out here 14 I look maybe baby sometimes
they don't list all of them of all those
books which one sold the most I have no
idea I honestly don't know what about a
thousand days of John F Kennedy in the
White House
probably that did what year did you
write them here with that in 1965 and
before that you were doing what before
you wrote that book right you know how
much time did you spend with the Kennedy
administration well I can join the
Kennedy administration
very soon after the administration began
and then I resigned
the day after Dallas because I felt the
president the new President Lyndon
Johnson ought to be see have his own
people people whom he could work and
whom he trusted and Johnson was
persuaded major to stay for the
transition so I stayed for a few more
weeks and then resigned and wrote a
thousand days when you look back on that
administration and you look back on the
book that you wrote have you changed
your mind about anything that you saw
when you're in there with the last 30
years of time between it but I wrote a
second book called Robert Kennedy in his
times where that came out dozen years
after a thousand days by which time more
information was available and
perspectives had changed and so on so
that I think my mature adjustment of the
Kennedy administration comes in the in
the second book what's the biggest
legacy as far as you're concerned I
think the biggest legacy I mean there's
some specific legacies such as the test
ban treaty for example and the movement
toward relaxation of tensions in 1963
the civil rights fight began in 1963 and
the space success beginnings of the
exploration of space and so on but I
think the most general sense was that
what Kennedy tried to wanted to do is to
tap the latent idealism of the American
people as FDR had done when he when Jack
Kennedy and I were young and there's
Wilson they've done when Jack Kennedy
were born he believed strongly that this
is the that we were capable of
intelligence reason generosity in
national policy
would were you older or younger than
John Kennedy he was born in May 1917 I
was born in October where did you meet
him I gone to college a college
classmate was his older brother Joe
Kennedy who was killed in the war I knew
Joe Kennedy I was aware Jack Kennedy was
a couple years later because he was had
to take a year off because of sickness
he was the class of 1940 I was aware of
him that I did not know him until after
the war when he became congressman from
the district in which I lived and
senator from the state in which I lived
so we got to know each other in the late
40s and 1950s what impacted the
assassination have on you personally I
couldn't I mean they were the mixture of
grief horror and incredulity it was a
shattering time shattering thing to have
happened to the brilliant capable man
who was robbed at the chance of
fulfillment of his life and his hopes
and it wasn't itself introduced the
whole decade of it seemed it seemed one
of spreading violence one sort or
another culminating occurs in the 1968
assassinations of Martin King and Robert
Kennedy one had it's almost the feeling
that this whole social fabric was
unraveling in that strange decade what
do you think of the current discussion
which says that if the media had applied
the kind of microscope that did they do
to the current President on his personal
life if they'd had done that to Jack
Kennedy that it would have been a whole
different atmosphere well I doubt that
because I mean the current theory seems
to be that everyone in Washington knew
about parade of bimbos through the White
House and that they covered up because
they liked Kennedy or because the rules
deflected that kind of interval anywhere
that you read Ben Bradlee spoke Ben
Bradlee was Jack Kennedy's closest
friends in the press as head of the
Newsweek bureau he was of the nerve
center of news gathering there Ben
Bradley says writes that he did not know
about these things IRA certainly was not
aware of any kind of the waywardness
which would interfere with the conduct
of public business what do you think it
was much exaggerated what do you think
of this whole issue as a historical you
know discussion I mean is this is this a
very value at all well I think if you're
writing personal biography the president
says it's of interest I don't think it's
a matter of public concern the I think
they you know there's word I think that
the American people have reacted with a
certain and hardly surprising maturity
to this question with regard to
President Clinton I don't think people
deplore what is the link they admire
what is alleged about his conduct but
they do think it's his own business and
they separate it's a separate question
from his success as a president I think
the the adultery test once I the year
and the Gary Hart was forced out of the
presidential contest in 1988 the Robert
Kennedy book awards that year was
divided between David garrow's bogey
Martin Luther King and a book by
Elizabeth Rebecca about Cambodia I was
chatting with the two authors at they on
this occasion and we're talking about
Gary Hart and then of the marriage that
Martin Luther King of course was a man
of a certain sexual waywardness in his
private life he was a great moral leader
and made a great difference to this
country Paul Pott of Cambodia was
apparently a man strictly faithful
husband man who deeply believed in
family values all he did was to murder a
million
countrymen i think if there are limits
to the adultery test is it standard to
apply to a statesman what did you do and
your work after the White House where
did you go back to when you went back to
being a historian I am after the White
House
I spent some months at the Institute of
Advanced Study at Princeton and then was
asked to be at writer I decided not to
go back to Harvard how long had you been
Harvard I'd been there I lived in
Cambridge Massachusetts and Thoreau said
when he left Walden he said I greatly
enjoyed my time at Walden but I decided
that I had other lives to live and so I
was attracted by an offer of those
rights our professorship but in the
humanities at the City University of New
York so I came and did that how long so
I came there about 90 I was there until
I retired for about four nearly 30 years
what year did you retire I retired about
a year and a half ago and are you
writing a memoir I am writing memoir
I finally finally persuaded the right
man was which I guess I better do well I
can still remember anything so where are
you in that process I'm in the second
world war and how much how much how big
is this gonna be one volume I doubt it
I'm afraid you'll either be one long
volume or two shorter values and when do
you hope to complete it when I complete
it let me go back to your book hate
speech you're right about this in here
what is it hate speech is speech which
incites racial religious or ethnic
antagonisms and one sort or another and
the question is whether hate speech
should be suppressed now of course the
suppression of hate speech
would the require an abridgment of the
First Amendment of the Constitution as
interpreted by the Supreme Court Justice
Holmes once said that the First
Amendment it's not just license for the
speech with which we agree obviously
there was no great virtue in that but
it's license for the speech that we hate
and the FIR do to try to identify hate
speech it involves the hokum to suppress
it raises the whole specter of
censorship and censorship of that kind
would be hostile to the purposes of the
First Amendment
I think in hate speeches is it's hateful
but I think the way to deal with it is
just as Brad that I said was that more
speech not less speech let me read that
quote because I have that it's on a page
before that Brandeis you know did you
ever know him yes I knew what Justice
Breyer did where did you know him
he was a friend of my father's and I've
with my parents I visited justice and
mrs. Brandeis in their summer cottage in
Chatham Massachusetts on Cape Cod and
there's a school named after the
Brandeis University is and wealth of
messages when was he on the Supreme
Court
he was a it was a novel you put on the
Supreme Court about 1915 by Woodrow
Wilson and he retired about 1938 or 39
what was he like he was a he was a
Minolta cement prophet really he looked
he looked rather he's tall and press he
looked like Lincoln anyway he had great
moral quality great moral intensity and
he was a very pretty man
here's the quote you haven't here
talking about speech no danger flowing
from speech can be deemed clear and
present unless the incidence of evil
apprehended is so imminent that it may
be fall before there is opportunity for
full discussion if there be time to
expose your discussion of falsehood and
fallacies to avert the
evil by processes of Education the
remedy to be applied is more speech not
enforced silence we get into that
discussion here about what do you put on
a network like this and almost
everything goes I mean if there's a
public event and somebody says some of
the things they say in these public
events that are you know don't sound so
good to some people's ears would let it
go should we do that yes I mean I do
what's the alternative to censor it has
there been a time when we have tried to
censor things here well I think there
have been always been censorship with
regard to pornography to allegedly
obscene materials and so on and I think
there's some point in that particularly
keeping children whether they were on
children there well I but I don't think
I doubt that when James Madison wrote
the Bill of Rights that he had a hustler
in mind or some of the assembly poor
what a graphic magazine but I think what
he safar his speech having to do with
public policy or artistic expression and
so on we have to to fight for the full
liberty of the First Amendment but you
ride in this in regard to what's going
on on college campuses and
multiculturalism and political
correctness what's your take on all that
well I can we understand why college
administrators would like to clamp down
on
only abusive speech I think that there
could have a entirely understandable
concern for kids who come from minority
groups who are insecure and feel
themselves intimidated by complacent
white bullying students I mean it's a
very difficult situation for college
ministries
hence the development of speech codes
speech codes or means of prohibiting
various forms of speech from as a matter
of administrative convenience you
weren't gonna descend by administrators
go to that but I think they make a
mistake I think there are other forms of
persuasion including I think the remedy
as Brandeis said this much more speech I
think the kind of said more of a
challenge to college presidents College
Dean's professors faculty members is to
point out to the bullies and me and the
racists among their students of course
what the meaning of it is and what the
implications of it are I think that's
gonna be doing much more good in the
long run than speech codes which
infringe to the fill on the First
Amendment you point out in your book
that at the University of Pennsylvania
they have a separate yearbook for blacks
what do you think of that idea well I
don't think it's a very good idea
I mean I'm of that generation believes
very strongly in integration and
assimilation and I think that anything
which I mean multiculturalism is a fact
of life we've always been a
multicultural country for the beginning
I think for a long time the minority
cultures were diminished and excluded
but one of the great themes of American
history has been the movement from
exclusion to inclusion and it's been a
fall during movement still incomplete
but yet it's a kind of persevering
direction in which virtually we are
going and I think the
they insofar as multiculturalism means
recognition of the an already
achievement it's absolutely essential we
should have much more of that as far as
it means looking at things in different
perspectives to arrival of Columbus for
example from the viewpoint of those who
met him as well as from the viewpoint of
those who sent him that's a very useful
- problem with multiculturalism is when
it becomes when it rejects assimilation
and integration and when it tries to
establish and perpetuate and celebrate
separate ethnic and racial communities
then you we're moving in the direction
of Yugoslavia or at least of Canada yeah
there is a you ask a question here and
in your book it says can they be kidding
up there in Northampton and you're
talking about Smith College or
Northampton Massachusetts and you say
the office of student affairs at Smith
College has put out a bulletin listing
types of oppression for people belatedly
quote realizing that they are oppressed
and then they go on to list that you do
the sins of the oppressed ableism
heterosexism and lookism where did you
find this and what's it all about well I
I don't know I I have hope that Smith is
recaptured his sense of humor about
these things but I think it isn't look
at them that how is it look as the
belief that appearance is an indicator
of a person's value the construction of
a standard for beauty attractiveness and
oppression through stereotypes and
generalizations of both those who do not
fit that standard and those who do I
know I mean it's it seems to me the
desire to protect people reaches kind of
ridiculous proportions life consists of
hard knocks and the cave developing and
ability to deal with them I think the
notion that you should anything that
hurts or might be considered to hurt
someone's feelings should not be said
is a very dangerous standard the in the
sensitivity standard leads in the end
whose what happened to Salman Rushdie
Salman Rushdie wrote a book which the
ayatollahs of Iran regarded as
blasphemous is offensive to true
believing Muslims so they put a price on
his head the so called fatwa it's still
operative and he's poor old rusty can't
move anywhere without bodyguards well
that's the notion the hurt feelings
standard is cannot survive in the free
society
if we had the hurt feelings standard
throughout American history that would
have silenced mark twain ambrose bierce
mr. Dooley HL Mencken and so many other
people who've enlivened and illuminated
American life mr. Menken is on your list
back in the back of the Baker's this is
not the Baker's ya baker's dozen I guess
that's 13 isn't that 12 and his book was
the American language now would you have
agreed with him politically I'm very
much no no I'm making it with the great
writer and he was a wonderful liberating
sensibility of the force in American
life particularly in the nineteen
twenties he was a libertarian and he was
not that he was not a Democrat and the
small D says he regarded the masses of
people with a certain score and not
contempt and the boob wozy he called
them you say he seemed sour and
mean-spirited in the in the nineteen
thirties at a time when we were in a
great in the depression because he
regarded all political all politicians
as charlatans he couldn't stand Theodore
Roosevelt or Wilson there Bryan or
Franklin Roosevelt and he was very much
against the New Deal and so on so
politically when I didn't always agree
with him but I admired him tremendously
his writer and the braiding force and
there's a great champion of the American
language
which he saw is different from the
English language she was grateful
ologist and when he collected words
sought out their origins and the
American language is a fascinating book
he was wonderful writer the fascinating
compilation of the the way that the
American language had departed from the
English language I wrote something down
speaking of language I want to ask you
about language how much you think about
when you're right the phrase I wrote
down here was bogus blather you say I'm
confident to see the situation in our
universities I'm confident will soon
write itself once the great silent
majority of professors cry enough and
challenge what they know to be bogus
blather how hard did you work on that
phrase I don't know I said these phrases
slip into one's mind or pan their word
processor how much time do you spend
thinking about language and you're right
I think if nothing else I suppose I mean
I try to I think about the the the
precision of the clarity of expression
requires you to think about what you're
trying to say and I was great influence
of my life as a writer was a historian
and critic of half a century girl named
bernard de voto what was his history
books year of decision across the wide
Missouri and so on are still read but he
was among other thing as he taught for a
while at Harvard taught English
Composition and he was a ruthless critic
he would write insulting and goading
comments and whenever he saw something
which seemed pretentious or murky or
obscure so it enforced on me a great
concern for clarity and precision in the
use of language I use the dictionary
whenever I want to make sure we've got
the right shade of expression but
clarity and language depends on clarity
and thought and the one of the great
virtues of writing is it requires you to
the Dean Acheson used
how do I know what I think till I hear
what I say
what kind of dictionary do you use
American Heritage Dictionary I think and
of the things that you know you the
research or the reading or the writing
of those three elements of what you do
which do you enjoy the most
I enjoy them oh there's nothing more fun
than an archival research where do you
do it
oh I've done it many institutions
through the country the Library of
Congress New York Public Library
Massachusetts Historical Society Harvard
University Library so and so on Kennedy
Library the Roosevelt and Kennedy
Library in Boston the Franklin Roosevelt
Library in Hyde Park I've even been at
the Herbert Hoover Library in West
Branch Iowa and time passes going
through manuscripts very agreeably very
quickly but I like writing too what what
do you do when you're right word where
do you do your writing I do my writing
and in the in our apartment in New York
City on a word processor and how long
you been doing a word processor I
haven't been on a word process for eight
or ten years I guess I think it's a
glorious invention the ease of editing
and transposition and so on when I think
of the years I've spent typing and
retyping the same page in order to get
clean copy I regard the word processors
right blessing now as you're working on
your memoirs where are you in that
process research writing think'll I do I
I I do come on I mean I I have a the
research has been basically done so
whenever I enter a new phase of my life
I pull out folders and refresh my memory
look at letters or diaries which I've
kept intermittently through my life and
memory is place a lot of tricks but also
generates memories
you suddenly begin to think about things
you hadn't thought about for 40 or 50
years when you kept Diaries in your life
how did you do it physically what did
you put it on though for a while when I
could i hand-write he was still legible
I kept it in handwriting but the last 40
years or so I've typed you have a lot of
notes over the years yeah and what part
of your life do you have the most notes
from I suppose I have a lot from the
Kennedy years because I felt that I had
an obligation as an historian given this
seat on the making of history I felt I
had an obligation to know things as I
saw them happen did you do it right away
after you saw him every day night well I
would work often till 2:00 in the
morning I wouldn't do it necessarily
every day but nearly every day and you
have stories that you've never told
before that you'll end up writing in
your memoirs and how do you you tell us
how you approach a memoir versus say
either an autobiography or a history
book well I don't know the difference
between a memoir and an autobiography
but you you try to recapture your what
you thought at some other time in your
life and how that made a difference to
your life
and anything amusing or interesting that
happens or people you met it serve takes
its farmers it goes you know Bobby would
read this book think it sounds awfully
conservative have you heard that before
well I don't think it's conservative at
all it's a very liberal book it's just
defending you're the First Amendment and
so on yes well occasionally you get
there they I think there's a fallacy at
the notion that militant
multiculturalism is a liberal view it's
not a liberal view it's really a view of
the other
new left of the 1960s and if you
remember the 1960s the new left regarded
liberals as their main enemy that they
weren't worried about conservatives but
the new left and the radicals of the of
the sixties are am much opposed to
liberals this is a book that most
liberals wholly agree with if they it's
the aging radicals of the 1960s and
their equivalents in the 1990s who are
they who feel that to talk about one
people is injustice and who want to
perpetuate ethnic and religious and
racial differences they're bound to lose
Ryan I think the most telling statistics
is the rate of intermarriage marriage
across ethnic lines marriage across
religious reliance marriage across
racial lines more Japanese Americans
marry Caucasians and marry other
Japanese Americans so many Jewish
Americans marry non-jews the people are
worried about the future of a Jewish
community of a Jewish identity the
black/white marriages have quadrupled
over the last generation and the
attitude toward what used to be called
miscegenation has been absolutely
transformed so I have confidence that
love or sex will defeat those in the end
we wanted this unite America now
periodically you've come out with a
survey in The New York Times about that
president's the United States when did
all that start well it really was my
father's like many other things that I
inherited the presidential polls from my
father he first in 1948 for Life
magazine polled historians and political
scientists as to how they would rate the
presidents and then in 1962
The Times New York Times magazine asked
him to replicate that poll so we did it
and in 1996 The Times magazine asked me
to do the poll again I did so I did it
and then about a couple months later
that I think it was the National Review
came out with a poll by Walter
MacDougall which showed a little bit of
a difference as to how the categories
and one of the criticism they made of
that poll was you had of the 32
historians only a couple of them were
conservative did that did you read that
part of the yes yes well there were
seven conservative historians there and
not the most historians it must be said
tends to be in control but we did
Forrest McDonald and some other
conservative historians in the pool why
is it that most historians are liberal
well I think because they but they see
the necessity of changed the changes the
essence of history and therefore
remember sympathetic to change then
conservatives if history if there were
if she changed were not the essence of
history there'd be no point writing
history if everything stayed the same in
your book you talk about the
african-american baseline essays
what were they or what are they well
they're a series of essays which
published some years ago in
as part of the Afrocentric movement
these essays attempt to show that most
good things in the world resonated in
Africa they talked about the glories of
African kingdoms and so on there the
river a gross form of ethnic
cheerleading they're rejected by most
thoughtful black historians and they but
they had a vogue I think people felt
people of good heart generous intention
felt that if this made young black
students study harder if it made them
feel better why not use this as a basis
for reformer or changes in the
curriculum so the number of cities for a
while played around with one version or
another of the Afrocentric written
influenced by these satalia the books
treatises to which you were referring I
think the vogue is passed partly because
of the leadership of of black
intellectuals who feel that this is not
the play to deal with the question
partly because there's no clear
relationship between academic
performance and progressive self-esteem
and glory if I mean self-esteem really
comes from achievement it's not a cause
of achievement achievement it's a
consequence of achievement and I've
never noticed that telling Greek
Americans about the glory that was
Greece Greek American kids or Italian
American kids about the grandeur that
was Rome improves their academic
performance what's the new york history
curriculum new york history curriculum
as a result of the Iroquois Lobby
there's a
a section calling for a making a great
point of the alleged influence of the
aracari confederation on the formation
of the American Constitution I mean they
they you can understand the pressures of
ethnic groups religious groups gender
groups school curriculum they want to
get there nice word said about their own
paths and so on but that as a result is
icky of that is the corruption of
history current history what do you
think of it basically the books you see
coming out on the day-to-day
week-to-week basis well I it all depends
some of some of them are very good some
of them are very hasty superficial
sensational books I think the I think it
was great appetite for history in the
u.s. I mean success of Ken Burns as
documentaries success of the History
Channel the success of c-span which
provides the kind of coverage of
contemporary history I mean number of
people you know better than i watch
question time and House of Commons and
so on all this is it shows a real desire
to look to learn history I like I think
there's some objection to memoirs by
palatability people who in government or
out of government on the ground under
this is re these are kiss-and-tell books
and so on I'm not against them I think
they enriched the historical
documentation if they're written rather
quickly where the people involved are
people mentioned in the book are still
alive they have their chance to did you
refute a Reba's or criticized so that
the whole process of
Publishing memoirs and other people
commenting on them and supplementing
them or denying them all this enriches
evidence available for the future
historian you had one point in that book
point out that in 1900 America was the
most literate country in the world and
that now we're 45th what what happened I
suppose it's a a decline of the public
school system which is a large part of
this the public the public schools were
much more the kind of public school
systems been associated with the the
decline of the city and particularly the
decline of the inner city where public
schools that are valiantly doing still
carrying on but so often they've been
deformed by violence and by pressures to
to lower standards
it's where more and more society of
depends on the filling out of forms so
the illiteracy becomes real real problem
other countries since 1900 have also
become more literate and that's another
reason why we have declined in the
standing correct your dad how much are
you like your father you know he's not
here we're the same orbit how much were
you like him
well I were I certainly have inherited
many thoughts for my father and as well
as and there's a preoccupation obsession
with with history he was a better
teacher than I and more involved in
academic life I have been he was
he was less of a political activist I
suppose and less involved in the kind of
Olympics and about current current
policies do you have children of your
own six six - what are the age range
they range from 25 to over 50 what kind
of work are they in one of them runs a
world policy instituted Stevens really
could written two or three books we're a
Policy Institute at the new school in
New York my youngest son Anton Robert
works for the hill the weekly newspaper
covering Capitol Hill and Washington was
he 25 he's 25 um they have a daughter
who runs a public relations firm in
Boston another daughter who's a painter
and teacher of art and sound he was a
independent television producer Andrew
did the one on Adlai Stevenson and PBS a
couple of years ago a few years ago and
son of steps on who's a entertainment
lawyer and did you try to pass on what
you got from your father in history to
any of the kids I it's more a matter of
the atmosphere in which one grows up and
I mean yes I Stephen and Catherine then
have both written books dealing with
history Catherine what about the
Cultural Revolution in China and these
made television documentaries for
historical sorry Robert is writing
current history and
so on so what's the best training for
someone who wants to be a historian
curiosity about the past and having good
teachers in school in college and when
you were teaching at the City University
of New York what kind of courses did you
teach
I thought seminars colloquia in
diplomatic history and then when German
intellectual history the next year I all
didn't hate it between diplomatic and
intellectual and did you notice any
change I mean you showed that the
literacy this country's gone way down
but did you notice any change in the
kind of students you got over the last
20 years or so
well graduate school you get people who
are fairly qualified and who have a
dedication they want to get a PhD degree
in order to teach her to write and I had
both Harvard and City University had
very good students I think that they
were there's much less training and
writing it seems to me then there were
used to be I think the true-false exams
exams which you don't have to write
anything you just indicate and then you
feed them into a computer I think
they're Menace I think that people
should be forced to write all the time
from the earliest grades
I think clarity and expression in
communication is the essential thing I
think there has been a decline in that
now looking back over the people you've
known in your life forget the obvious
the Jack Kennedy's and the Robert
Kennedy some people like that who have
you enjoyed knowing the most well I
think there two people one American and
one English the American was Reinhold
Niebuhr of the great theologian and you
have him as one of your baker's dozen
yes his book the irony of American
history I learned a great deal for him
from him at Harvard well I actually met
him through the Americans for democratic
action a DA and but I became great
friends and I've learned a great deal
front from him
from his writings another thing which
man I thought Berlin who died the other
day the brilliant sparkling and high
intelligence wide range great with great
humanity and the great in the great
historian divide is so when do you find
yourself connecting with somebody what
what is it about those two that that you
personally enjoyed so much well I think
partly personal chemistry
apparently that I learned a great deal
from them and in history besides Jack
Kennedy who was your favorite president
and why FDR
I think FDR was a man really knew how to
be president them of course I grew up in
FDR was president its capacity to bring
back a stricken nation remember that
when he became president quarter of the
labor force was out of work couldn't
find work our gross domestic product was
half of what had been a few years before
the banks were all closed and so on its
capacity to bring you revive this
country through leadership and
experiment and audacity and then of
course his wisdom about the war so I
think he's led our country through the
worst depression in our history and the
greatest war in our history and that's
why nearly all the polls end up with
Lincoln Washington and FDR's are three
various residents and with a little bit
of time we have left where would you put
Bill Clinton at the six-year mark hard
it's hard to say I think he's a he's a
man the high intelligence impressive
technical command of complicated issues
when the spirit moves him his genuine
eloquence and the spirit moves him most
in the most crucial issues we face as a
nation that is a question of race on the
other hand these he's made some
decisions such as the so-called welfare
reform signing the welfare so-called
reform bill which I regret
it's mixed record you can't you could
never tell till they uppers over and our
guest has been the author of this book
which is in its third edition it came
out in 91 92 and now 98 this uniting of
America reflections on a multicultural
society doctor not doctor but Arthur M
Schlesinger jr. thank you very much
thank you